think it took me a long time to build up
my confidence to feel like I could put
out a record and I think that was always
in the back of my mind like I knew I'd
be incredibly unhappy if I didn't put
that record out but I guess it was like
testing the waters and
as I kind of acted and modeled before I
kind of had this thing in my head where
I was like oh God if I also do music
like that's just so annoying
I wasn't sure if anyone was going to
take me seriously for music and and now
I'm like you know that was an uphill
battle I remember when I made my record
and then I sent it to my label I got an
email about saying we're not interested
in looking at this record we don't do
models and actors and whatever so what
made you send it again
because I felt like I deserved to be
listened to